hi everybody my name is Jenova Chen I'm
sephiroth color no you're not no I'm not
but this is game life and it's our first
episode 4 2009 we're going to be talking
about one of the most anticipated games
of the beginning of 2009 flower for the
PlayStation 3 that's fair factoring
flower is a game that is very difficult
to describe we have tried many different
answers but still we can we haven't find
the the best or the optimal answers so I
described as an interactive poetry or
poem well we use very abstract you know
see no reason and symbolism to put the
player on our emotional journey you go
through a series dreams from these urban
flowers you know but in this apartment
there's a bunch of flowers living there
outside of our mates or you know huge
city but each flower has their dream you
know sort of flower dream about nature
dream about being with the grass and
with other flocks other flowers dream
about the color and the wind on so the
player is really this row of you know
dream fulfilled you know you're going to
each flower to dream and you get to
perform what they desired and then to
hear them and by doing so the apartment
that these flower lives in gets to be
improved we design flower to be a very
accessible game because we feel anytime
you provide a new experience there will
be new audiences you know there might be
people who you never considered should
be a gamer might be a good fit for the
game so we tend we wanted to make the
control really simple so if you look at
the screen the control of the game does
not rely on anything on the controller
it's not from the sticks it's not from
the button it's just by tilting the
controller if you took left you know the
the Vagos laughs and if you too bright
it goes to the right and it's a it's a
one-button game so any surface button
that you press or do essentially the
same thing which are low the players you
fly fast you know if you release your
button you know then it slows down and
if flower you touch what blue and by
blooming certain flower you know
mysterious event would happen in the
world and as the player you're trying to
understand how these are connected each
other in together what we are trying to
do is to expand the definition of video
game you know trying to explore what is
possible to be communicated through
video game as an interactive art form as
a game maker and as an adult I wanted to
create games that would be attractive
and meaningful and relevant to adopt you
know basically I'm say i want to make
game that i will play you know it's very
selfish but i think that's how most of
the saints works our philosophy is to
try to expand you know the possible
emotional experience that video game can
communicate beyond you know the
traditional old and joinery raj the
stimulation and the competition and the
fun and the kunis but to find what is
out there and and what has already been
accomplished by other medium in the past